Hey guys.
We are here at the Dome
with Brian Brushwood from
the YouTube channel The Modern Rogue.
Hey man.
This is The King of Random Channel,
which means I need to see
something melt or blow up immediately.
How about both?
You make a compelling argument.
[Caption by Judy V. at Y Translator]
[Music]
Today, we are going to follow up
our Aluminum in Clear Ice experiment,
and see what happens
if we do the same thing using molten
copper rather than molten aluminum.
So what's the difference
with copper versus aluminum?
So aluminum melts at
a lower temperature than copper.
Copper melts at almost
2,000 degrees Fahrenheit,
so it may cool down and just start to
harden in a way that aluminum didn't.
If that does happen, there are
a couple other things that may occur.
We might just cast copper inside
the tunnel that we drilled into the ice.
That wouldn't be the coolest reaction,
but it would still be fairly neat.
It's also possible that
there will be some steam,
but not the explosive amount
of steam that we saw before,
and it could launch our molten copper
up out of the top of the block of ice.
Man, there are no
wrong answers in Science.
Something cool is going to happen.
It's time to find out what.
Alright, so where do we begin?
We've got to melt down
some copper, right?
Yes.
We've got our foundry.
We've got propane.
We've got a bunch of copper ingots,
and we are just going to get
those going in the foundry.
It'll probably take 30-ish minutes
for those to get nice and melted down.
We want a nice, thin, pourable copper liquid,
which at that point,
is going to be glowing beautifully.
And while we do that,
we can get a hole drilled in our ice,
and get it set up under our pouring device.
Awesome.
Let's, we can't start fast enough.
Let's go.
Here we go.
Oh, what a great thunderous sound.
So the flame's coming out the top.
They have a greenish hue to them.
Yeah. So the cup we're melting this in
has been used for melting copper before,
and as it gets hit with the high heat,
some of the copper starts oxidizing.
Oxidizing copper
has a tendency to turn green.
It's not because it's not haunted?
It's also haunted.
Okay there, that makes sense.
Yeah.
Alright, so how deep do
we want to go in here?
We want to go 2/3 to almost 3/4
the way down through the ice.
We want to make sure there's
like a really good nest down in the ice
where the copper can settle.
And do we want it to be wide
at the top or thin all the way down?
We'll go thin all the way down,
and then after we have
the tunnel carved into it,
we'll widen the top just so
we're better able to pour the copper in.
We don't have to aim quite so precisely.
Got it.
It's snow.
I'm from Texas, I'm easily amused.
I think that's good.
And this block of ice,
which when I picked it up,
it was completely clear,
is now full of these little micro cracks
or tubes, or something like that.
And I don't really know what they are.
>> But it looks cool as heck.
>> It looks amazing.
Well, it's open.
I'm just going to drop
some copper pipes down in there.
Oh, that's wild.
Oh, look at that.
There it goes.
That' amazing.
Very, very heat
conductive.
Yeah, dude.
The heat goes from
the liquid into the solid copper,
>> Just that fast.
>> really quickly.
This is really gonna be impressive.
Oh, that looks amazing.
That is pretty heavy.
Copper is...
That was scary.
Is that leaking at the bottom?
Nope, part of the ground
is made of sawdust.
Got it.
Hopefully, I can carry this with these tongs,
and stay close to the ground.
Look out.
It's very close.
This rock is gonna work
as a wedge to hold our cup in.
Alright.
Let's go.
Oh.
Three, Two, One.
That looked awesome.
Well, it still does look awesome,
but it's not exploding.
>> Oh, I think we just cast something gorgeous.
>> There is iron melting down
through that block of ice.
That is amazing.
Did you see how fast it
traveled through the block?
Oh, Steve.
Now, it's melted all
the way down through the bottom,
and it's pouring
the boiling water out.
That's, that's extraordinary.
It think we're probably
safe to go in at this point.
Are you
sure?
No, we're pretty sure.
That copper is not that hot
anymore.
Wow, look at this.
That poured straight through.
That just destroyed that block.
Not in the same way
we were expecting but...
That is nuts.
Oh, it's still encased in a block of ice.
I can see what we cast in
the ice, its just down at the bottom.
We made art.
Oh, that
looks awesome.
That is a weird little copper ingot.
It's a wicked copper worm.
I'm just gonna set this
on top of our block of ice.
It's still so hot.
It's tunneling.
Oh, that's amazing.
I did not expect there
to be so much of a heat reservoir.
Yeah its still melting its way through.
What a surprising result.
That just tore through that block of ice.
Look at this. Come see on the bottom of it.
You can see that it fell down,
and then went sideways,
and just popped right out.
So Brian, the result you were expecting?
I mean, there's no
wrong answers in Science,
but now I have a better question.
All I want to know is how far down
would it tunnel through just a stack of ice.
I mean, all the way down?
That would be interesting to test.
And this clear ice I have actually comes
in a block about three to four feet high.
I smell a follow-up.
It would be a very good thing to test.
I said that they were three
possibilities that I could think of.
This is sort of one them.
But even the one where I said
we would cast copper in the ice,
it's not really what it did.
It cast the copper and then it just decided,
"Nah, I'm out of here."
And drilled its way all the way through.
It's interesting.
The little hints of what was
happening as it was bubbling and cooling
as it went through, but I can't believe
what a reservoir of heat it remained,
even after it tunnelled
through that block of ice.
Brian, our block of ice didn't explode,
and I actually have a little bit of extra.
Oh man, what should we do with it?
Good question.
Go golfing?
Yeah.
Three. Two. One.
That felt good.
Everything hurts in my hand.
That was
awesome.
Three, Two One.
Nice.
Oh, yeah.
That was great.
Definitely feel the
shock up to about your elbows.
Wow.
>> That was very satisfying.
>> That was fantastic.
Wow, look at how, this looks gorgeous.
That felt great.
This is art.
Brian, what are you guys working
on over on The Modern Road?
We just made a perfect copy
of my co-host, Jason Murphy's face.
We're making a
ballistics-gel version of his head,
and we're gonna fire
projectiles point-blank at it.
It's going to be amazing.
I bet he's really happy that
you're using an analog of his head,
and not his real head.
I mean, there's a reason
I insisted he have the fun experience
of getting his face copied.
Very cool.
Guys, go check out
Brian's channel, The Modern Rogue.
They update new videos every Friday.
It's a ton of fun.
Hey guys.
Grant jumping back in for
just a second to remind you
we're giving away a
Nintendo Switch and Mario Kart 8.
There's a link down
in the description right now.
You can click and
get your name on the list.
We're doing a random drawing
for subscriber appreciation.
And we're also sending
you the gift receipt because
if you don't want the Nintendo,
you can take it back
and get the cash instead.